y ahora
[Música]
buenas noches
como soy músico los músicos a veces
necesitamos un programita para ver el
orden de las canciones en este caso va a
ser mi orden para la charla text que voy
a dar
amigos
se dice que en los colegios hay tres
tipos de estudiantes se dice que están
los buenos estudiantes sobresalientes se
dice que están los estudiantes promedio
y también se dice que están los malos
estudiantes los pésimos estudiantes o
como lo dicen los profesores los niños
problemas
según mis profesores y según el sistema
yo era un pésimo estudiante y un niño
problema esta es mi libreta
lamento informarles que las notas de esa
libreta están todas sobre 20 entonces
tenemos un flamante 9 como una nota más
alta un glorioso 6 y me recordó el 3
no pusieron esos tres puntos por poner
el nombre del examen nomás
la situación es la siguiente los
profesores le dijeron a mi familia
efectivamente que este chico es un muy
buen estudiante
así que una terapeuta le dijo a mis
papás porque no le compran una guitarra
de repente si le compran una guitarra y
a través de la música este niñito
problema puede sensibilizarse a través
del arte puede tal vez éste mejorar su
retención su atención su memoria y tal
vez con ese camino pueda mejorar en sus
notas lo de las notas no pasó para nada
pero había encontrado una pasión había
encontrado algo que me encantaba me
encantaba tocar la guitarra esa guitarra
mi papá y mi mamá juntaron platita y con
mucho esfuerzo me compraron esa guitarra
que antes había tenido cinco dueños o
sea en pocas palabras nadie que esa
guitarra porque era horrible pero yo la
quería muchísimo y es así amigos que
como en una guitarra tan fea me gustaba
tomarme fotos con guitarras de otras
personas
[Risas]
la situación es que yo ya había
encontrado para mí lo que yo quería yo
quería hacer música quería tocar
guitarra estaba todo el día escuchando
guns and roses
entonces éste le dije eso a mi familia
no ya los profesores y todos y lo
primero que dijeron fue no hay forma o
sea el arte la música la guitarra vas a
morirte de hambre vas a caer en los
vicios las drogas vas a terminar siendo
un pelucón con tatuajes
y
y bueno llega el momento de decidir el
futuro el futuro no lo establecido y
aquí es donde entran dos elementos en
tensión los estudios la carrera
profesional
y el arte lo que me apasionaba la música
entonces tomé una decisión con el perdón
de los publicistas decidí estudiar
publicidad porque no tenía muchos
números entonces dije creo que en ese
tiempo que no esté bien los números
puedo tocar mi guitarra y así dedicarme
a mi instrumento y a la par estudiar
esto por complacer a la familia a los
amigos no porque dices pues qué haces
toca guitarra dicen vagabundo no hace
nada pero en este caso yo era un
estudiante de publicidad las situaciones
que a la par trabajaba en un bar de
miércoles a sábado de 7 de la noche a 4
de la mañana dio 4 de la mañana porque
en esa época no había plan zanahoria
entonces nos digamos de largo tocando
todas las noches las situaciones que un
día dije no puedo más simplemente no
puedo seguir estudiando publicidad no
puedo seguir haciendo algo que no me
apasiona yo tengo que ser músico y así
llegué a un consenso con conmigo mismo y
con mi familia decirles saben que voy a
dejar publicidad y me voy a dedicar a la
música
lo que ellos me dijeron fue bueno todo
bien tu problema no fue lo mejor me
dijeron hasta lo que quieras es tu
problema
entonces ese bien tengo mi guitarra mi
cable y bien me dedico a la música pero
la música era tocar en el bar todas las
noches de siete de la noche a cuatro de
la mañana
es así que en un momento encontré dos
cosas en tensión también que eran este
yo en algún momento tuve la idea de
estudiar en el conservatorio no porque
dicen esto quiere ser músico estudias en
el conservatorio entonces fui al
conservatorio y dije cómo será el examen
de ingreso y me decían bueno tienes que
tocar este por ejemplo mozart
no yo mozart yo sólo escucho miranda
guns n' roses geo con con mozart no
entonces llegó un momento en el cual
dije voy a grabar algo para mis amigos
que va a ser hacer mozart no este una
pieza de mozart combinada con rock con
música popular con metal no
en esa época yo no tenía una cámara ni
nada y mis amigos tampoco entonces como
eran estudiantes de audiovisual mis
amigos iban y pedían la cámara a la
universidad y me graban tocando la
guitarra y es así que hice la marcha
turca de mozart en metal
no no
jaja
[Aplausos]
la situación es que este vídeo era para
mis amigos o sea tenía comentarios de
mis amigos esto yo lo subió a youtube en
el año 2009 hace diez años mis amigos
comentaba no soy aquel chevere por ahí
uno que otro oye que basura que feo
estas así
la cosa es que este
un día despierta y veo que ese vídeo ya
no tenía las 30 visitas de mis amigos
ahora tenía como 500.000 y tenía
comentarios de todo el mundo
dije hoy esto es una ventana es una
ventana de mi trabajo de hacer música de
repente quién sabe de repente puedo
salir del bar que sería genial
encontré un estilo de vida dije que loco
o sea yo en el colegio era el peor
académicamente no las matemáticas los
números y acá era mi música está en
cuatro cuartos hay 500.000 visitas hay
50 mil suscriptores dije volvieron las
matemáticas a mi vida pero de una manera
hermosa entonces la situación fue que
dije voy a seguir con esto de las
tensiones no y dije por ejemplo el himno
nacional del perú un símbolo patrio algo
ósea
recontra patriota es algo este
representativo pero qué pasa si esto lo
junto con algo que siento que también me
representa que es el rock el heavy metal
entonces hice una versión heavy metal y
rock del himno nacional
ahí está un joven y lo sano charly parra
en la foto
es así
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y
y esta versión del himno nacional a la
que le tengo muchísimo cariño
se volvió viral le abrió muchas puertas
a mis proyectos a mí como solista a mis
bandas más gente tuvo acceso al material
de mis bandas se realice bastante
viajecitos ya la vez también hubo algo
bien particular que fue la aparición de
haters haters y trolls de internet no
osea los haters y trolls de internet
como la palabra lo dice no el hate es
gente que sea no hacer realmente una
crítica constructiva u objetiva no hay
gente que realmente hace críticas
destructivas menosprecian y minimizan
nuestro trabajo y en mi caso hay un
montón de tipos de haters este por
ejemplo están los haters que odian mi
música detestan mi estilo de tocar
guitarra detestan a mis bandas también
están los que me odian a mí como persona
que les caigo súper mal y ahora hay un
nuevo estilo de hater que son los que me
odian porque sus flacas les dan like a
mis fotos en instagram o sea eso ya es
incontrolable eso ya mismo
la situación es de que esto de los
números y las cifras y la ventana de mi
trabajo hizo que me llegue una placa de
youtube por los 100.000 suscriptores
este había encontrado finalmente cómo
hacer que mi música tuviera una ventana
y no sólo eso sino que finalmente dejé
el bar o sea realmente dejé el bar y
pude conocer un montón de escenarios fue
bien divertido este la situación es que
dije ya vamos a hacer algo más extenso
todavía y dije voy a utilizar esto de el
punk y el metal no son dos géneros
musicales que a pesar que vienen del
rock
cada uno tiene características y este
estilos distintos
por ejemplo el punk está bastante basado
en lo minimalista pero a la vez la
revolución la rebeldía
y el heavy metal tiene un lado un poco
más virtuoso pero a la vez oscuro
entonces lo que hice fue un comparativo
que se llamó punk versus metal
y dice así
[Música]
la situación es que este vídeo llegó a 8
millones de visitas
o sea eso ya para mí fue como que guau
gracias a ese vídeo este comencé a tocar
en bastantes bandas en bandas de perú
toqué en una banda de francia toqué una
banda de canadá este salí del bar y me
fui a nueva york fue bien chévere fue
muy bonito
me tomé unas el fia y en parís soy yo
para decir mamá mira
e
y bueno con esto también vinieron
y bastantes cosas buenas bastantes cosas
también no tan buenas por ahí ciertos
excesos ciertas cosas de las cuales esté
aprendí muchísimo la verdad que aprendí
muchísimo y esto de que yo me tomaba
fotos con las guitarras de otras
personas y que tenía mi guitarra que no
me gustaba
resulta que pasó el tiempo y con todo
este trabajo me convertí en el primer
latinoamericano con una guitarra de una
corporación o sea esa guitarra es la
guitarra charly parra
lo más paja es que esta guitarra no es
que solamente la tenga yo no es una
guitarra que se vende en diferentes
territorios del mundo
entonces medio de que eso también es
algo que todavía me cuesta creer todavía
no sé a qué mandé una foto mía me compré
tu guitarra yo como guau y no es la
primera foto entonces me pone muy
contento
la situación es que también aquí tenemos
esta otra atención cuando me dijeron
esto del conservatorio de el examen moza
artes de la música y yo siendo un músico
de música pues rock música no metal
resulta de que se dio la oportunidad de
unir esto
mi estilo a la música con un estilo de
música académico y fue un ir tocar en un
ensamble sinfónico de rock sinfónico
y dice más o menos así
sí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
la situación es la siguiente yo creo que
esto de las cosas que están en tensión o
sea experimentar con cosas que están en
tensión han sido vitales para este
proyecto también creo muchísimo que
muchas de las razones por las cuales
nuestros proyectos a veces no se llevan
a cabo es por tener miedo a la crítica
no a los haters a que van a decir miedo
a experimentar osea de repente esto no
va con esto y por eso muchos proyectos
se quedan ahí o sea uno de repente dice
voy a hacer esto y pasan cinco años y
dicen pucha no lo hice no de repente
ahora si lo hago porque esto tal vez y
combine con esto hice muchas pelis y lo
combino y de repente aparecen todos los
haters y se pasaron 10 años y no debería
ser así o sea lo mismo pienso de cómo
sería pues cuántos cuantos niñitos están
en el colegio y por el sistema y por los
profesores piensan que de repente no son
tan buenos y de repente tienen otros
talentos
por si acaso él no es mi papá
este es este es uno de mis referentes en
la música es la de guns and roses
para mí fue un gustazo conocerlo fue una
cosa de que bueno hasta el día de hoy
también no lo puedo creer
[Música]
esa es otra cosa atención
los panamericanos
[Música]
eso fue prácticamente cajón peruano con
una guitarra eléctrica unas cosas que
para mucha gente todavía sigue esto en
tensión pero yo creo que funcionó dentro
de todos
básicamente hoy en día esa es mi oficina
hoy en día ese es el lugar donde me
siento feliz el lugar donde no puedo
creo que será mi trabajo porque es
realmente mi pasión
y creo que eso tiene mucho que ver con
esto de de romper con lo establecido de
ir en contra de no sé por qué los dos
elementos en tensión no pueden unirse
porque tener miedo a la crítica que van
a decidir la ciudad a decir un hater
esto o lo otro simplemente siento que
hay que salir adelante y bueno si tienen
algún proyecto alguna meta no dejar que
pasen cinco o diez años por estas
limitaciones porque como ven todos
pueden no y bueno muchas gracias
[Aplausos]